how often did the two of you encounter
an independent filmmaker who's
intimidated by attorneys maybe they have
you know fears maybe they feel they're
going to be taken advantage of they
don't understand the process and what do
you do to alleviate those fears yeah it
happens a lot and I think the major fear
is cost you know oh we can hire we can't
talk to an attorney because we don't
have the money to pay for one and that's
such a misconception because typically
it's much less expensive if somebody
comes to us early on in the project
rather than later and asks us to fix
things because once they're in a
position where they really need an
attorney that's when it's gonna cost a
lot more money so we're constantly
alleviating people's fears that you know
it's okay and if you can't afford us
it's okay you don't have to retain us
and we have this wonderful book that is
a resource I'm actually was just talking
to someone today who had who basically
asked me in about 30 seconds how do I
make a movie but he had a lot of
questions in there and I said you know
you should really get this book I said
this is the book that's going to tell
you basically what you need to know to
make a movie and give you the resources
that you need to get it done in terms of
contracts and agreements that you that
you will need when you're producing a
film in fact one of the things about
this fourth edition is that every
contract in here that is discussed with
all the hints in the background and the
what to do if they disagree has after it
a an address where you can just type in
and download a clean copy of the
contract so you can change it and we
tell you how to use them it's it's very
user friendly and it is designed for
filmmakers who may not be ready
financially to hire a lawyer this this
book will get them started okay well
let's talk about what are some of the
things that may happen if first off
let's suppose they are scared of the
cost but the alternatives in on the back
end could be a lot more
costly what are some of those scenarios
if they did not have their ducks in a
row let's suppose when they the movies
ready it's ready to go to theaters
they've got a distributor they vary but
I would say by the most common one is
not having signed agreements with people
which results in those people having a
valid copyright claim over elements of
the film so so many films are done you
know I know I know I don't know what tie
wait there he is hold hands and walk
into the sunset and also people are just
working for a day do I really need
someone to sign an agreement if they're
just working for a day but what happens
is anybody who holds a camera anybody
who has any sort of arguably creative
contribution to the film owns the
copyright to that contribution unless
there's a writing that says otherwise
so we get that work for hire language
and some things work for hire that means
the person who's hiring them actually
owns a copyright and if you don't have
that you can have a pieces of copyright
floating all over the place with all
these different cameramen that you've
used and for as an example for the prop
person or the costume person they all
these people are making contributions
which are copyrightable certainly if you
build a prop if you design a costume so
you really need to get little little
deal memos there's a form in the book
but you have to get you got to ever get
everybody to sign on otherwise the
producer who's paid for everything and
thought he or she owned the copyright
may only own a piece of the copyright
and that can get to be very very very
problematical get the written agreements
before you let people do work on the
film yeah and just tacking on to that
you know the real issue becomes delivery
so so many producers don't understand
what delivery is or even know what that
word is and that means you know when you
have a film you have to actually if it
gets sold you actually have to deliver
it to somebody and not only the film but
all the paperwork attendant to the film
because whoever is buying it wants to
know
that you own all the copyright the chain
of title is clear all of these things
that we described in the book and talk
about in the book but it's it's
interesting how people don't understand
that and once they go to deliver then
they have to backtrack and then like oh
man I haven't talked to the person in
three years I've never been able to find
them and they have to do that and so it
just becomes a lot harder trying to do
things after the fact than doing things
as you go along I think just isn't
anything else in life so let's say I'm
doing a little indie short I'm paying
for it out of my own pocket I'm the
writer director producer I've hired a
gentleman or woman off of Craigslist to
be my camera person and I found some
actors I would need to worry about it
right and you're doing it at my house
I'd be fine correct no no but that is
exactly the way people think about small
films and and and even worse all our
friends are getting together on Saturday
and we're going to make a short
typically know-nothing signed hire
somebody off Craigslist typically you
would but it's amazing how many people
don't think a wit about these things and
then they sell the film and it's a night
mayor and expensive it's so easy to get
the proper releases at the time but to
go back later it's difficult and and
sometimes triggers a feeling that
perhaps they should receive some money a
feeling that they wouldn't have on
Saturday when we're all holding hands
and singing Kumbaya
you